-♪♪ Impressions ♪♪
-Now, here's how it works.
We'll take turns hitting -
-I just -- I'm holding this?
-That's yours.
-Okay, all right.
-We're gonna take turns
hitting this button here,
which will activate the
musical impressions generator.
-Yep. Yep.
-Okay, now, it'll land on on
random singer that one of us
can do an impression of.
-Gotcha.
-And then one random song title.
-And random song title. Okay
-Whoever's turn it is has to d
an impression of that musician
singing that song.
-Gotcha. Okay.
-Okay, here we go.
Since you're my first guest,
why don't you go first?
-I'll go first.
Okay, here we go.
All right. Random generator.
-Bob Marley.
-"Hush Little Baby."
-"Don't Say a Word."
-Okay, yeah. Okay. All right
all right, all right.
-Roots, like, a Bob Marley...?
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ Hush little baby ♪♪
♪♪ Don't say a word ♪♪
♪♪ Papa's gonna buy you
a mockingbird ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪ And if that mockingbird
♪♪ If it won't sing ♪♪
♪♪ Papa's gonna buy you
a diamond ring ♪♪
-Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪♪ Oh, papa's gonna
buy you a diamond ring ♪♪
♪♪ Say the word, and papa'
gonna buy you a diamond ring ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness!
Oh, my goodness!
No, you don't get -- No.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, gosh.
Okay. That was great.
-Oh, wow. That is terrifying
-My turn. Here we go.
[ Beeping ]
-Dave Matthews.
-"Yankee Doodle."
[ Laughter ]
-Dave Matthews type of jam
Type of some --
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ Yankee Doodle went to town
♪♪ Riding on a pony ♪♪
♪♪ Stuck a feather in his hat
♪♪ And called it macaroni
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-That's exactly...
-♪♪ Called it macaroni ♪♪
Okay. Here we go.
Oh, my gosh. That's amazing.
-Keegan, you're up.
[ Beeping ]
-All right.
What do we have here?
REM.
-Is that me? You?
-"She'll Be Coming Around
the Mountain."
-Can you do REM?
-I think.
We'll give it a whirl.
All right, all right.
One of us -- Yeah.
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ She'll be comin' 'roun
the mountain when she comes
♪♪ She'll be comin' 'round
♪♪ When she comes ♪♪
-♪♪ Comes ♪♪
-♪♪ She'll be comin'
'round the mountain ♪♪
♪♪ She'll be comin' 'round
the mountain ♪♪
♪♪ She'll be comin'
'round the mountain ♪♪
♪♪ She'll be comin' 'round
the mountain ♪♪
♪♪ She'll be comin'
'round the mountain ♪♪
♪♪ She'll be comin' 'round
the mountain ♪♪
♪♪ She'll be comin'
'round the mountain ♪♪
♪♪ She'll be comin' 'round
the mountain ♪♪
♪♪ She'll be comin'
'round the mountain ♪♪
♪♪ She'll be comin' 'round
the mountain ♪♪
♪♪ She'll be comin'
'round the mountain ♪♪
♪♪ She'll be comin' 'round
the mountain ♪♪
-♪♪ She'll be comin'
'round the mount-a-a-ain ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Fantastic.
-♪♪ Comin' 'round the mountain
Are there any more words
to that song?
-I don't know. No.
Here we go. That was great
[ Beeping ]
-Bruce Springsteen. Yeah.
-"Bingo."
-Like "Bingo was his name-o"
♪♪♪♪
-"Bingo was his name-o."
How you guys doin' out there?!
You all right?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys want to go
to the farm?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right. Everyone
wants to go to the farm.
You know? Heh.
♪♪ There was a farmer
who had a dog ♪♪
Bingo was his name-o
♪♪ B-I-N-G-O ♪♪
-♪♪ B-I-N-G-O ♪♪
-♪♪ And Bingo was his
nay-ay-ay-ame-o ♪♪
Thank you very much!
Good night!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
That was fun.
I could do this all night.
-This is a blast.
-I love you, buddy. All right.
Keegan, last one.
-Here we go. My last one.
All right. Here we go.
All right.
[ Beeping ]
Frank Sinatra.
"Itsy Bitsy."
-Frank Sinatra is doing the...
-"Itsy Bitsy Spider."
-Okay, all right.
-Never heard this.
-Here we go. Here we go.
Okay. Watch this.
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ The itsy bitsy spider
♪♪ Came up the waterspout
♪♪ Down came the rain ♪♪
♪♪ And washed that spider out
♪♪ Out came that crazy sun
♪♪ Hey, and dried up
all that rain ♪♪
♪♪ And the itsy bitsy ♪♪
♪♪ Kooky ring-a-ding
little spider ♪♪
♪♪ Climbed up that spout
ag-a-a-a-a-ain ♪♪
-Yes! [ Laughs ]
-Yeah!
Ohh!
Thank you. Thank you.
-Give it up for
Keegan-Michael key.
We'll be right back with more of
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Come on back.
-♪♪ The itsy bitsy spider
went up that waterspout ♪♪
-[ Scatting ]
♪♪ Scooby doo, that spider
-♪♪ Spider ♪♪
-♪♪ Washed the spider out